(piano music)
(clothes shuffling)
(chair dragging)
(sighs)
(footsteps)
(phone clicks)
(sighs)
(toilet flushing)
- [Radio DJ] Listen to music ad-free
with Songify premium for only $7.99.
You'll have unlimited access to
our spotlight artist of the month.
♫ Now we're on the way
- (groans)
♫ On the way
♫ We're gonna seize the day
♫ Now we're on the way--
(piano music)
(footsteps)
(sighs)
(rope snapping)
(man hitting the ground)
(sighs)
(car door opening)
(people chatting)
(guitar music)
(metal clanking)
- If you need anything let me know, okay?
(bag falling)
(drawer closing)
- Oh, sir, I can take care of that.
- No, I got it.
- [Store Clerk] Thank you.
(whirring)
- Oh, no problem.
- Is there anything I
can take care of for 'ya?
- No, I'm good, thank you.
- Do you happen to be
looking for safety codes?
Cause they're really hard to find,
and hardly anybody ever finds it.
- Nah, I'm all good on codes so...
- I mean I can help
you with anything else.
- I'm good, thanks.
- You sure?
- Alright we have coir
rope, nautical rope,
torn rope, polypropylene
rope, parachute rope,
twine rope, rope twine, pretty much
everything you ever need.
- I had no idea there were
this many kinds of rope.
- May I ask what you need it for sir?
- Just a good house rope.
- Oh, a house rope?
So you're doing some remodeling?
- Yeah, you know, I mean I have like
a hammer and a drill, and I feel like
I need a good rope in the kit.
- Okay, well we have this
nice general purpose rope.
- Probably need something
a little more substantial.
- Okay, well we can do that.
Let's see...
- Just in case there's and
earthquake or something.
I might need to kick open
a door and repel to safety.
- So a rope that can hold
your own body weight?
- Yeah, that would be perfect actually.
- What do you weigh, about 175?
- 155.
- Well, we have this nice climbing rope.
(whirring)
- Do you have anything less colorful?
You know, something they would use
to tie people down to train
tracks back in the old days?
- Okay, natural fiber rope.
- Perfect.
- I know what you're doin'.
- Okay?
- I respect it.
Taking your life in your own hands,
wanting to get out
while you're at the top.
Everything's fucked anyways.
Who says quantity over quality, right?
Have you ever seen a dead body?
- No.
- I was in the army back in the day.
- Thank you for your service.
- Nah, I wasn't exactly on
the front lines, I was a cook.
Anyways, there was this
PFC, he was on kitchen duty.
Found out he couldn't take it anymore.
Got drunk while on fire watch,
found out that we didn't
lock the gas ovens,
and... boom.
'Cause who in the hell wanna
fuck with an oven, right?
- Yeah.
- You know people shit
themselves when they die?
- No, wait really?
- It's a mess man.
Hey, we got tarps on isle 39F.
- Thank you.
(footsteps)
(piano music)
(scratching)
- Dammit!
(phone vibrating)
(sighs)
♫ Now we're on the way
♫ On the way
♫ We're gonna seize the day
♫ Now we're on the way
♫ On the way
♫ We're gonna seize the day
(swinging)